[Música]
Hola son muchos los acontecimientos que
tienen lugar en una semana en el mundo
pero en este espacio vamos a conversar
sobre los temas más destacados en los
últimos cinco días bienvenidos esto es
una semana en el mundo para conversar
sobre los temas que hemos seleccionado a
lo largo de esta semana hemos invitado a
Raquel godos ella es subdirectora de
América Latina para la agencia Efe
también ha sido corresponsal en la
ciudad de Washington donde cubrió
diferentes temas relacionados con la
política de Estados Unidos Raquel
bienvenida del programa como termina su
semana Muchas gracias Santiago Muchas
gracias por la invitación muy bien Vamos
a ver qué nos ha deparado esta semana
con vosotros vamos a analizar lo que ha
pasado también con Trump que es
protagonista protagonista esta semana sí
claramente también nos acompaña aquí en
el estudio de Francia 24 John pose él es
abogado magister en periodismo es
también experto en temas políticos y
jurídicos como termina su semana John
Bienvenido al programa Hola Santiago
gracias por la invitación un saludo
especial a la gente que nos ve hasta
ahora pues terminaba una semana bastante
Yo diría que con emociones encontradas
empezamos la semana muy asustados muy
temerosos por esa posible escalada del
conflicto entre el racio y Rusia y
Ucrania ya ha desescalado ya vamos a
hablar del tema luego la expectativa que
generó la candidatura de Donald Trump en
Estados Unidos que a pesar de que ser
una noticia ya cantada Pues sigue
generando expectativa y ahorita
finalizamos un poquito emocionados por
el mundial de Qatar 2022 también con
polémicas alrededor pero de que emociona
emociona tanto a los que les gusta como
las que no nos gusta tanto el fútbol nos
congrega porque es un evento sin duda
masivo un evento masivo a escala
internacional desde Madrid en España se
conecta a esta conversación Emilio Ortiz
él es periodista especializado en la
Unión Europea también estudia populismos
y movimientos euroescépticos y
geopolítica escribe para la Revista el
orden mundial Emilio Bienvenido al
programa Gracias por estar con nosotros
como termina usted su semana del otro
lado del Atlántico allá en España
Bueno una semana más otra semana más
intensa como muchas como todas ya
últimamente
no sorprende que la agenda esté llena
porque Llevamos una racha bastante
importante de acontecimientos
muchos hechos internacionales sin duda
alguna también se conecta desde la
ciudad de Quito en Ecuador se une a esta
conversación Giselle jacomellas
periodista internacional ha sido también
productora multimedia y presentadoras
corresponsal para la voz de América
Giselle Bienvenida al programa y Cómo
terminó usted la semana allí en la
capital ecuatoriana
Muchísimas gracias Santiago Mira Que
terminamos esta semana muy emocionados
con la camiseta de nuestro país
totalmente puesta porque abrimos el
mundial y realmente todo lo que ha
rodeado los comentarios de estos días
nos ha dejado un poquito preocupados
pero sabemos también la calidad de
jugadores que tenemos sabemos la calidad
de gente que está allí y que son
personas a las que les ha costado mucho
llegar así que vamos a estar comentando
esto y con todo el detalle por supuesto
lo que se viene respecto a lo que está
ocurriendo entre Rusia y Ucrania todo
eso también obviamente nos toma la
atención durante estos días y que somos
ya 8 mil millones de personas en el
mundo y esto sí que pone la cuestión
pues muchísimo muchísimo a pensar la
cabecita y aparte de las cuentas pues
hay que considerar que podemos hacer
desde cada uno de nuestros nichos no son
cifras que uno difícilmente puede como
dimensionar en su cabeza cuando uno dice
Bueno En este planeta 8000 millones de
personas habrá recursos para todos
nosotros vamos a ver en unos minutos lo
vamos a comer la vamos a conversar y a
debatir aquí entre todos ustedes también
nos pueden acompañar con sus opiniones y
todas sus preguntas las pueden dejar a
través de las redes sociales ustedes ya
las conocen arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios es numeral una semana en el
mundo f24 pues voy a comenzar entonces
en Estados Unidos porque allí pues había
un Secreto a voces había muchísima
expectativa en torno a este tema el ex
presidente de Estados Unidos
Donald Trump anunció esta intención de
querer llegar nuevamente a la casa
blanca Trump es entonces aspirante a la
nominación del partido republicano un
partido que está presentando muchísimas
divisiones internas un partido que tiene
otras figuras políticas con las mismas
aspiraciones de llegar a la casa blanca
y también un partido que carga a cuestas
esos resultados de las últimas
elecciones de medio término que no
fueron lo esperado para muchos de ellos
pregunto entonces
por Raquel aquí en la mesa de France 24
porque aspira a Trump nuevamente a la
candidatura a la presidencia qué tanto
tiene esto de cuestión de ego o cuestión
de necesidad
personalmente creo que se trata de una
cuestión de ego pero en un porcentaje
muy elevado Además creo que nos
enfrentamos ante un personaje que es
claramente megalómano tiene una
necesidad de poder elevadísima e incluso
pese a los malos resultados de las
legislativas como mencionabas Pues no ha
cejado en el empeño de presentarse
incluso sus asesores le planteaban no
hacerlo tan cerca de la fecha de esa
derrota o semi derrota porque en
política las expectativas también marcan
que es una victoria y que no lo es pero
no les hizo caso y Igualmente asistimos
esta semana esa a ese anuncio de esa
presentación a la candidatura
republicana tiene opciones creo que
tiene menos de las que él esperaba los
resultados en las legislativas en
muchísimos estados han sido muy por
debajo de lo que él esperaba apenas uno
o dos candidatos han conseguido
revalidar o ganar el escaño en la cámara
de representantes y la victoria de los
republicanos en la cámara baja es
tremendamente pírrica no es muy estrecha
con lo cual se avecinan un par de años
interesantes porque la manera que yo
creo que los republicanos conociéndoles
un poco van a manejar esto va a tener
que ver mucho con Cómo cambiar los
discursos la capacidad que puedan tener
de cambiar y de girar el discurso en el
parlamento en la cámara baja con esa
mayoría que van a tener Pero además hay
una cuestión muy interesante que
hablamos poco pero
el liderazgo republicano Kevin mccarthy
no tiene los apoyos y ahora va a haber
también una batalla interna para ver
quién lleva el liderato republicano el
liderazgo en la presidencia la cámara
baja y eso también puede abrir heridas
no y claramente las divisiones internas
al interior de los republicanos van a
ser Va a ser un tema decisivo para esas
candidaturas y cómo se van a organizar
las fuerzas entonces en el en el
congreso le preguntó a John por este
lado y ahorita cambiamos la la forma de
hacer la ronda de preguntas para que
todos hablen en diferentes turnos yo en
adelante sí Yo estoy de acuerdo con
Tania que tiene un gran porcentaje de
ego pero también hay que mencionarla
suspicacias que han explicado ya muchos
de que esto trata de debilitar los
procesos judiciales a los que se
enfrenta Donald Trump porque sin duda
con el micrófono y la tarima ahí a su
favor los procesos judiciales van a
debilitarse y son procesos judiciales
que si bien el departamento de Justicia
no ha acusado formalmente a Donald Trump
pues son procesos que tienen pruebas
sólidas y que puede llegar a un curso
mayor entonces ahí está la suspicacia
puede ser que Donald Trump también esté
buscando debilitarse ahora opciones si
bien la bandera roja que se esperaba ver
en estas elecciones de medio término no
se lograron pues Donald Trump es un
animal político y Estados Unidos tiene
el terreno polarizado y no hay en la
política un terreno más fértil que la
polarización Así que Donald Trump a
largo plazo puede volvernos a sorprender
vamos a ver qué pasa Lo cierto es que no
tiene ahorita muchos contrincantes
dentro del partido republicano ahí se
base barajan algunas opciones el
gobernador de la Florida puede ser muy
popular en la Florida pero no sé tanto a
nivel nacional su ex vicepresidente Mike
pence Cómo va a ofrecer una alternativa
distinta cuando fue el vicepresidente de
Donald Trump entonces a nivel si viene
el partido está atravesando por una
crisis interna a nivel interno también
Donald Trump puede posicionarse a largo
plazo sé que el panorama para Donald
Trump no es muy alentador actualmente
pero a largo plazo puede sorprendernos
qué piensa Emilio en la ciudad de Madrid
Bueno yo creo que
digamos que Trump recupera su voz No En
primera línea pero como decía Raquel yo
creo que hay que contar también con el
hecho de que él pretender más opciones
de las que realmente tiene Y eso es un
problema a la hora de gestionarlo por
parte de una persona que está
acostumbrado a a ganar o hacer creer que
gana
en Donald Trump pesa mucho el discurso
no pesa mucho el mensaje mucho más casi
el que el contenido de lo que de lo que
propone yo creo que hace el anuncio en
un momento en el que está muy debilitado
en el que el partido
está dividido como hemos dicho y yo no
apostaría mucho dinero en caso de tener
que hacerlo por una victoria incluso de
Donald Trump en las primarias yo creo
que ron de santis puede tener cierto
recorrido de aquí
a 2024 hay que pensar que falta año y
medio más incluso para para las
elecciones entonces lo que ahora vale
Quizá no valga dentro de casi dos años y
cerramos esta ronda con Giselle en la
ciudad de Quito sus impresiones
Claro que sí pues yo coincido con
ustedes pero quiero que tomemos en
cuenta también algo importante que es el
uso de la red social que el expresidente
está haciendo debido a que esto le ha
impulsado muchísimo a que pueda tener
muchos más seguidores ahora se lo mide a
él también por el número de Seguidores
el número de afiliados que tienen su red
y por supuesto a través de ella él está
consiguiendo muchos más adeptos Pese a
que obviamente sabemos que el trabajo a
favor de los latinos y de los migrantes
no es tan positivo es lo que trata de
recuperar en este momento Precisamente
es esa confianza que el estadounidense
el norteamericano Podría tener en una
nueva gestión corregida de Donald Trump
y creo que él hace lo que podría ser un
oso cuando vamos a un campamento y Es
como empezar a rugir para ver hasta qué
punto nosotros podemos escapar del
Bosque o simplemente quedarnos a ver que
resulta al final de todo esto
bueno confianza si es claramente lo que
se tiene Donald Trump al aspirar
nuevamente a esta nominación republicana
Giselle hago la ronda la inversa
comienzo con usted para cambiar un poco
la dinámica y quienes Pueden seguir a
Donald Trump después de haber visto cómo
es su forma de gobernar a lo largo de
esos cuatro años en los que estuvo en la
Casa Blanca hay estadounidenses hay una
masa política muy fuerte que lo sigue
pero los estadounidenses estarán
dispuestos otra vez a tener este tipo de
gobierno Donde había un discurso muy
fuerte donde se criticaba los medios
donde también empezó a tener un poco de
discrepancias con Los Grandes aliados de
Estados Unidos y prácticamente pues se
disgustó con china que es un Aliado
comercial importante
yo creo que en este momento sobre todas
las personas que son de extrema derecha
sí estarían apostando nuevamente por
Donald Trump recordemos que él tuvo un
acierto precisamente con la Corte
Suprema girando la más hacia el lado de
la derecha recordemos algo también que
Estados Unidos es un pueblo que también
está Regido por la parte religiosa y en
este momento hay una gran lucha sobre
todo por la que están dando marcha atrás
especialmente en la parte del aborto
Entonces esto sí podría volcar en algún
momento tal vez la simpatías hacia un
Donald Trump que como decía hace un
momentico puede corregir un poco en las
riendas de lo que venía haciendo un poco
mal no un poco distraído digamos así
Ahora me parece a mí que él podría
llegar inclusive a algunas personas que
antes no había logrado captar como son
aquellas personas que están favor de la
vida obviamente y que a lo mejor por
allí también va a dirigir su discurso
económicamente hablando posiblemente
pueda convencer a algunos más de que la
situación con China o el distanciamiento
con China
convendría de repente a Estados Unidos
sin embargo creo que hay que irse con
muchísimo cuidado porque aunque hablaba
de que las redes sociales le podrían dar
inclusive a él una mayoría de aceptación
tendríamos que ver al final de la
campaña para saber exactamente si es que
el ex presidente Donald Trump Podría
tener más opciones de las que tuvo
inclusive cuando ganó la presidencia por
primera vez en ese orden de ideas yo
tengo mis dudas normalmente no Expreso
mi opinión en los programas pero yo no
veo tan fácil un escenario de elección
presidencial Trump biden Raquel cruzamos
desde quito hasta acá hasta el estudio
Esa esa elección presidencial va a ser
Trump yo lo veo bastante improbable
sinceramente hay muchas cuestiones en
estos dos años que nos queda y que va a
empezar la campaña a las primarias Bueno
ya ha empezado con su propio anuncio
hay varias cuestiones a tener en cuenta
uno de los republicanos es la cámara
baja como decía antes van a intentar
virar el mensaje para poder acusar a
bayren de no sé que estaban hablando
ayer algo así como de abuso de poder ya
están Tejiendo Algunas estrategias para
llevar a la cámara baja y hacer uso de
esa mayoría en la cámara baja pero a la
vez hace unos minutos el fiscal general
de Estados Unidos ya nombró al consejero
especial para ver si se presentan cargos
contra Trump por la toma al Capitolio Y
eso va esa va a ser la la pelea no esa
va a ser la pelea discursiva el mensaje
que va a estar llenando todas esas
peleas mediáticas y políticas y todos
los debates más allá del aborto que como
dice Giselle Es verdad que es un asunto
que yo creo que ha marcado a favor de
los demócratas esta estas elecciones
creo que hay muchos mucha Mucho peso
reli en Estados Unidos pero también hay
mucha consciencia sobre los derechos de
las mujeres y era un derecho de
consolidado desde hace más de 60 años
con lo cual yo Incluso en estados donde
se ha votado A favor o sea se ha votado
para ver en plebiscito si estaban A
favor o no de proteger el derecho al
aborto estados tremendamente
conservadores han votado a favor de
conservarlo con lo cual esos mensajes ya
van dando una idea de por dónde Trump
está pisando en falso No Y ahí eso la
pérdida de ese derecho al aborto es una
consecuencia de que Trump cambiara esa
Corte Suprema a una corte mucho más
radical Ahora tiene que ver cómo logra
creo que plantearse como un líder serio
en un contexto internacional
tremendamente complicado yo no sé si
muchos estadounidenses conservadores
querrían por ejemplo tener a Trump de
presidente con una guerra en Ucrania que
ha sido provocada por un líder que es
afín al propio Trump O sea hay muchas
variables que hay que tener en cuenta
pero creo que lo va a tener complicado
de Cara a 2024 y hay uno no sabe si el
estadounidense promedio evalúa todas
esas variables cruzo desde el estudio
francés 24 a Madrid dejo para el cierre
a John acá en el estudio Emilio adelante
Usted que piensa cómo va a ser ese
escenario de esa elección presidencial
en Estados Unidos vaiden Trump
yo creo que no yo coincido bastante con
con Raquel en casi todo lo que ha dicho
no veo que Trump lo tenga tan fácil como
como mucha gente cree tampoco
apostaría a una candidatura de Joe biden
y es verdad que volvemos otra vez a lo
mismo de que el escenario en el que
Trump ganó en 2016
no es ni mucho menos el mismo que
tenemos ahora a nivel internacional
si algo hizo Trump
en la Esfera geopolítica durante su
mandato fue por ejemplo ser muy duro en
las relaciones con china con la guerra
comercial en esa guerra comercial ahora
mismo no va a poder insistir si es
presidente a partir de 2024 porque el
contexto internacional el mundo tal cual
está ahora mismo y tal cual va a seguir
estando dentro de dos años porque los
las disfuncionalidades que se están
generando ahora no van a tener una
solución a corto plazo es una ligerancia
en el discurso esa beligerancia en la
toma de decisiones a la hora de
desmarcarse en su relación por ejemplo
con la Unión Europea esa
ese excesivo pensar en sí mismo es
excesivo egocentrismo no le va a servir
a Donald Trump es decir tiene que mutar
mucho su forma de entender la política y
de entender el mundo si quiere
postularse como un presidente Útil para
Estados Unidos y para el cierre John Sí
Santiago Lo cierto siempre maduro o sea
estamos en un estado muy prematuro para
vaticinar si vamos a ver una contienda
Donald Trump Joe biden Lo cierto es que
ese ciudadano estadounidense Santiago no
analiza todos los temas Macro que
estamos aquí poniendo sobre la mesa el
ciudadano estadounidense no analiza la
situación en Ucrania temas Macro
producción
Exacto lo que le toca al bolsillo en su
día a día cuando va al supermercado
Cuando esta inflación gigante cuando ve
que la economía está pasando por una
crisis sí es mundial pero los
estadounidenses la están sintiendo mucho
eso es lo que ver ciudadano y el eslogan
de Donald Trump ya funcionó y la
situación y el entorno es el ideal
medicamento y Donald Trump la tiene
Clara y el ciudadano estadounidense
puede verse convencido por ese eslogan
por ese discurso populista para muchos
por parte de Donald Trump Entonces yo
insisto en que a largo plazo Tenemos que
tener cuidado con esa cantidad pero
fíjate que económicamente hablando la
inflación ya está muy alta y los
resultados terribles O sea no hay nada
más movilizador que unas cifras de
inflación como las actuales en términos
políticos y aún así en un escenario que
históricamente además siempre ha ganado
el partido opositor al que gobierna
desde hace más de 20 años no gana no
tenían un resultado tan bueno un partido
en el propio gobierno no en este caso
los demócratas yo creo que todos los
indicadores son muy poco halagüeños
porque en un escenario donde los
bolsillos de los estadounidenses están
resistiendo donde normalmente es caldo
de cultivo para que el partido opositor
pueda obtener buenos resultados donde
además históricamente en unas
legislativas de medio término pueden
tener esa ventaja sobre todo en el
primer la primera toma de contacto
después de la victoria de vaiden aún así
no lo hacen bien No lo tiene no lo tiene
tan fácil no tiene un camino fácil y
bueno esta historia apenas se está
empezando esa nominación pues va a ser
luchada con otros candidatos que también
aspiran a llegar a la casa Blanca vamos
a ver en qué termina toda esta historia
yo Les propongo que avancemos porque se
nos está yendo el tiempo y Tenemos
muchos temas en la agenda y esta semana
también hubo una cifra importante cifra
para destacar el mundo superó la Barrera
de los 8.000 millones de habitantes una
cifra que para muchos puede sonar un
poco apocalíptica para otros puede ser
un momento perfecto de reflexión por la
situación medioambiental además que
coincidió justamente con la Cumbre de la
cop 27 en Egipto Damián un pequeño
dominicano fue ese habitante 8000
millones que llegó a nuestro planeta
pero se pregunta uno Qué futuro le puede
esperar entonces al pequeño Damián allí
en la República Dominicana en un planeta
que no logra hacer ese equilibrio o
reversar el daño medioambiental o
revertir los efectos del cambio
climático Cuáles son las reflexiones que
qué sabor les dejo esa esa fecha esta
semana que nos nos dieron a conocer Esa
esa cifra importante 8 mil millones de
personas comienzo con Emilio para hacer
la ronda diferente Emilio adelante
Bueno yo creo que nos tiene que hacer
reflexionar no
es verdad que es una cifra que en cierto
modo asusta pero no nos podemos adaptar
a un mundo con 8.000 personas y es 8000
millones de personas perdón y es verdad
que los retos pues son
innumerables y depende de nosotros
cualquier análisis que se haga de si la
cifra es alta o no Si la cifra los más
apocalípticos nos dirán que igual nos
puede llevar al colapso o no eso va a
depender de las decisiones que tomemos
lo que está claro es que
ahora mismo
es complicado no ser optimista Pero
bueno viene en generaciones por detrás
que yo creo que que están concienciados
por ejemplo con la lucha contra un
cambio climático
creo que las los más jóvenes van
entendiendo también cómo funciona el
mundo cómo funciona multilateralismo que
no es lo mismo que generar dependencias
que nos puedan llevar a escenarios pues
como como estamos viviendo no con las
determinantes energéticas con Rusia todo
depende de cómo afrontemos esa cifra sí
John por acá en el estudio Sí yo creo
que la conclusión Santiago es esa que
lamentablemente no hemos podido lograr
cerrar las brechas de desigualdad sigue
habiendo desconfianza y crisis mundial
Esa es la conclusión a la que tenemos
que llegar ahora la buena noticia es que
el crecimiento demográfico para los
próximos mil millones por lo menos se va
a demorar un poco más que este esto
tardó más o menos 12 años los de pasar
de siete mil ocho mil millones cuando
seamos 9.000 tendrán que pasar 14 años y
medio casi 15 años entonces esperemos
que este está este proceso lento del
crecimiento demográfico nos permita
tratar de avanzar en esos objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible en cerrar las
brechas porque ahí está la crisis La
Brecha entre ricos y pobres crece cada
vez más y esa es el llamado y la
reflexión que tiene que dar esta cifra
apocalíptica para muchos algunos hasta
memes han sacado pero pero pero pero sí
invita a la reflexión a la reflexión
mundial si invitar una reflexión es
básicamente la gran conclusión Giselle
su opinión allí en Quito Claro que sí
Bueno mira por un lado nos preocupa
mucho Pero por otro también nos obliga a
mirar hacia otros lados África
subsahariana por ejemplo es una de las
regiones que más contribuye precisamente
a este crecimiento demográfico Y qué es
lo que ocurre allí son países de renta
muy muy baja de renta media países que
no tienen la posibilidad de poder
generar recursos para autosustentarse
actualmente Entonces a qué Llama a que
los países más desarrollados puedan
comprometer más políticas para ayudar
pero no necesariamente Desde allí
solamente sino también decimos desde
nuestros países que sin duda estamos
tratando de sobrevivir a una demanda
económica mundial muy muy fuerte en en
el caso de Ecuador por ejemplo nosotros
tenemos el dólar como moneda Y eso es lo
que nos ha ayudado a sustentarnos pero
aún así estamos trabajando en proyectos
de generación de recursos entonces quizá
con estas experiencias desde este otro
lado del Planeta llevarlas hacia el otro
lado hacia África y tratar de apoyar
para que estos países justamente de
renta baja empiecen a generar recursos
que les puedan ayudar en su crecimiento
particular y también Llamar al resto de
gobiernos del mundo a tratar de
redistribuir este proceso de riquezas a
tratar de pensar También en estos otros
países no nos olvidemos que lo que pasa
en el otro lugar del planeta nos afecta
a todos y a veces nos olvidamos que las
personas que más necesidades tienen
están pues pensamos que está muy lejos y
nos olvidamos que todo lo que ocurre al
otro lado también nos puede estar
afectando a nosotros en nuestras
economías nos Llama a tomar
responsabilidad desde cada uno de
nuestros nichos Como siempre digo a
nosotros como periodistas dar a conocer
las cifras revelar las cifras y sobre
todo lograr compromisos interesante
Bueno es muy preocupante no la situación
actual Yo creo que tiene que llamar a un
está muy bien los memes y hacer ese tipo
de
frivolizaciones de vez en cuando para
poder sobrevivir pero si vemos en la
situación y el calentamiento que está
sufriendo el planeta es gravísimo
más gente se implica más consumo y más
gasto de recursos y como bien decía
Gisela hay que analizar de dónde vienen
esos flujos de natalidad tan altos
porque hay un factor positivo en esta
lectura que también es que tenemos más
esperanza de vida no hay un avance a la
hora de poder vivir más vivir mejor con
una esperanza de vida y una calidad de
vida mayor y eso es una buena noticia
pero también hay que tener en cuenta que
capacidad tiene el planeta para poder
es decir y es cierto que hay continentes
donde también por las fuertes
condiciones socioeconómicas que son muy
complicadas Pues en estas familias en
África que mencionaba gisele lo que
hacen es tener hijos para poder ponerlos
a trabajar sí es una cuestión muy
importante no así de sencillo y es muy
grave con lo cual tenemos que empezar a
dar la vuelta y ser más conscientes de
lo que hacemos y también en qué
condiciones vamos a dejar el planeta
Para futuras generaciones pero lo que
mencionaba Emilio también es cierto las
nuevas generaciones son muy conscientes
de ello yo creo que además hay mucha
menos natalidad en la gente joven
también porque no tienen como tener
hijos no hay una un futuro económico
sólido que se lo permita pero en
términos generales hay mayor consciencia
y es probable que esa aproximación que
comentaba tenga que ver con una lentitud
Pero porque la generación que viene
detrás es más consciente
claro estamos gastandonos los recursos
del planeta me queda muy pocos minutos
ya del programa Tengo dos temas por
delante los pido entonces que sean
puntua sus intervenciones Tenemos que
hablar de Ucrania de lo sucedido a lo
largo de esta semana esos bombardeos
intensos en diferentes ciudades que
dejaron acerca de 10 millones de
ciudadanos ucranianos sin servicio de
Electricidad y sin servicio de
calefacción en un país en donde Ya
empezaron a caer las primeras Nevadas
por lo menos en kiev la capital ya ha
habido temperaturas bajo cero los
últimos días y también toda la
controversia que hubo por ese misil que
cayó en territorio polaco aquí empezó
una serie de informaciones
contradictorias que había sido lanzados
de Ucrania por equivocación por las
fuerzas ucranianas que no que fue de los
rusos
finalmente la escalada solamente duró
unas horas pero generó muchísima
preocupación a nivel internacional
comienzo con Giselle sus impresiones
sobre este tema preocupante lo que pasa
en Ucrania preocupante que ya los
ucranianos tengan que enfrentar este
invierno sin Sin óptimas condiciones de
Electricidad y calefacción
sí es una situación que igual nos debe
Llamar a todos a la reflexión Ahora yo
pienso que el presidente Vladimir Putin
se la está pensando dos veces antes de
dar cualquier tipo de orden esto lo puso
muy nervioso y creo que como analistas
nosotros debemos observar qué fue lo que
hizo Rusia al principio salió y dijo
nosotros no tenemos la culpa de esto
creo que ellos quisieron adelantarse
para evitar un mayor juzgamiento por
parte del resto de países ante la
reacción de Polonia frente a la
explosión de este misil el hecho de que
el presidente bolodomir selensky también
haya pedido entrar en la zona para poder
verificar significa que él quiere estar
absolutamente seguro y reconocer si
efectivamente este misil vino desde su
territorio pero lo cierto Es que ante la
escalada de de la guerra que podría
estarse dando en los próximos días a un
mayor si la humanidad está muy muy tensa
y creo que vale la pena rescatar también
la actitud de estuvieron en el comité
justamente analizando estuvo Francia
estuvo Estados Unidos estuvo Alemania
que no tomaron ninguna decisión
inmediata de aplicar ningún tipo de
artículo de la otan sino que se la
pensaron bien y creo que esa es la parte
positiva que se la pensaron bien En
beneficio del resto de la humanidad
porque sino ahorita la historia sería
otra si una reacción en falso en este
conflicto puede costar muchísimo a todo
nivel John si afortunadamente esa
posible escalada del conflicto duró tan
solo unas horas como lo decía Santiago
porque pues se veía venir una cosa
Trágica Afortunadamente no pasó a
mayores no hubo activación de ningún
tipo de artículo del tratado de
Washington gracias a Dios las
investigaciones preliminares y las
profundas arrojaron que lo más probable
es que el misil fuera un misil ucraniano
que por error terminó en territorio
polaco lo cierto aquí es que como dicen
en política si quieres la paz Busca la
guerra aquí la tendencia mayoritaria es
que en unos meses se pueden dar unos
diálogos o unas conversaciones y los dos
países quieren llegar lo más fuerte
posibles Ucrania quiere llegar lo más
fuerte posible y Rusia también por eso
la lluvia de misiles por eso la
manipulación de la información que
muchos han dicho por eso la búsqueda de
aliados por parte de Ucrania ya se
leensky hoy le bajó un poco el tono a su
teoría dijo no tenemos el 100% de la
velocidad porque él aseguraba que no era
un misil ucraniano que era un misil Ruso
entonces aquí vemos una serie de
estrategias tanto
militares como estrategias políticas
para lograr llegar aún en un futuro a
una mesa lo más fuerte es posibles Rusia
como lo decía está atacando la
infraestructura estratégica de Ucrania
la infraestructura energética Así que
vamos a ver qué pasa esperemos que esto
terminen unos diálogos en unas
conversaciones y no en una escalada de
conflicto Lo cierto es que con Rusia
todo puede pasar pero Rusia por lo menos
esta semana también se dio y prolongó
por cuatro meses más este acuerdo para
la distribución de cereales ucranianos
eso también de un respiro no solo
Ucrania y a Turquía que están son parte
de esta negocia sino al mundo entero por
lo menos para el invierno va a haber
trigo en varios países africanos Raquel
Sí yo creo que estamos ante un momento
bastante crítico del conflicto porque
los rusos tienen que conceder un montón
de terreno han concedido toda la zona de
Hardcore y unas ciudades claves en su en
su avance por tierra ucranianas y han
cambiado la estrategia hacia atacar
sedes o elementos eléctricos insumos
cosas fundamentales para pasar este
invierno que también están jugando con
ese factor no pero también Creo que
celensky se precipitó elevando ese tono
quiso echar un
órdago como decimos en España
a la alianza no Al fin y al cabo quería
comprobar Qué capacidad podía tener la
alianza de apoyarlo o no y no no me
extrañaría que hubiera recibido una
llamada diciendo cuidado Cálmate porque
es muy delicado y tenías que haber sido
mucho más cuidadoso Exacto con lo que
está ocurriendo así que bueno
efectivamente estamos ante un escenario
que para los rusos tampoco pinta también
vamos a ver hasta dónde llega la tensión
y donde también mantener la tensión
mediática porque al final la guerra
también es propaganda y también forma
parte de lo que se transmite a los
ciudadanos y a los medios de
comunicación a ver hasta cuándo le
aguanta Putin ese discurso dentro de su
propio país porque eso también influye
muchísimo en lo que pueda pasar en los
próximos meses Claro que sí dejó para el
cierre a Emilio en la ciudad de Madrid
muy puntual por favor
un poco que que Añadir yo creo que
entramos ahora mismo en los dos meses
más más importantes de lo que de lo que
llevamos de Invasión rusa de Ucrania
creo que diciembre y enero con la
llegada del Invierno un invierno que
además va a ser bastante duro en el no
solo no solo en Ucrania sino también
pues en Europa con países con una alta
dependencia energética todavía vamos a
ver yo pienso quizá un pequeño giro en
ciertos discursos a partir de enero no
cuando una vez pasan las navidades y yo
por ejemplo yo para nada descarto un
alto el fuego en esa semana de Navidad
creo que entraremos en 2023 con las
posiciones un poco diferentes con países
ya que no van a estar tan convencidos en
el apoyo a Ucrania Pues por una cuestión
de movilizaciones sociales y como digo
creo que estos dos meses van a ser
claves para el del conflicto bueno
rápidamente para el cierre del programa
Tenemos que hablar de la Copa del Mundo
de Qatar ya estamos a horas cuenta
regresiva ya para esa inauguración
allíendo hay muchísima expectativa y
también ha resonado en todas las
esquinas del planeta ese anuncio por
parte de las autoridades cataríes que
dijeron que no van a vender cerveza en
los estadios ni en la periferia de los
estadios solamente los fanáticos podrán
tomar alcohol en las zonas destinadas
para los fanáticos esto le bajó el ánimo
a muchísima gente muchos de los que ya
están yendo a listos para para ese
partido inaugural comienzo entonces con
Emilio muy puntual por favor porque me
queda un par de minutos nada más
un mundial sin cerveza sin celebración
en noviembre y en diciembre
todo todo es nuevo todo es desde mi
punto de vista como como aficionada al
fútbol extraño y
difícil de gestionar también la parte de
donde se celebra cuando se celebra las
limitaciones que se están
dando el mensaje de tratar de separar
fútbol y política que evidentemente en
Casos como este yo creo que es imposible
es un mundial raro es un mundial muy muy
raro un mundial muy raro no no dejamos
de lado el tema de los derechos humanos
y todos estos temas sociales pero ya los
hemos tratado en otros programas por eso
Simplemente me refiero a esta polémica
reciente del tema de la cerveza no es
que esté minimizando toda la
controversia que hay en torno a Qatar
dice él rápidamente usted que es
ecuatoriana y está con me imagino que
haciéndole muchísima fuerza a la
selección debutante que debutante no que
hace la apertura es la palabra correcta
exactamente nosotros estamos con mucha
expectativa Y saben qué fue lo que les
dijimos a nuestros jugadores y a los
hinchas que iban una vez que les
advertimos de esto es la cervezas que
ustedes van a dejar de tomarselas allá
Nosotros nos vamos a tomar aquí y cuando
regresen les vamos a dar el doble eso es
lo que nosotros queremos y estamos súper
contentos definitivamente lo hemos
tomado como una experiencia realmente
muy extraña como se lo decía muy muy
rara es un país sumamente especial
Qatar Y bueno pues a aprender de esta
experiencia y seguramente no se le dará
otra oportunidad dentro de poco a
ninguno de los países de esta zona del
mundo pero mientras tanto las cerveza se
quedan aquí
Raquel por este lado bueno Estas son las
consecuencias de celebrar un evento
mundial que es especialmente occidental
el fútbol es muy occidental celebrarlo
en un país como Qatar no Esa es como si
jugarán la final de La Super Bowl en
Pekín pues las consecuencias serían
Terribles yo creo que va a ser un
experimento social a nivel periodístico
es apasionante analizarlo desde fuera
ver cómo va a suceder eso pero creo que
vamos a asistir a muchas narraciones de
momentos que quisiéramos no haber vivido
creo que la FIFA se lo va a pensar dos
veces la próxima vez que quiera hacer
experimentos me imaginense Super Bowl
con nudos en vez de papitas barbecue
claro un escenario muy distinto John
para cerrar Sí yo concuerdo con Tania
que catar no tiene ningún pedigrí
futbolístico pero el fútbol y el mundial
de fútbol sobre todo Es una herramienta
geopolítica poderosísima y Qatar está
haciendo lo suyo
Qatar está utilizando ese escenario y
ese show futbolístico a su favor vamos a
ver hasta dónde no queda empañado por
boicots por alguna protesta social ya
incluso los futbolistas de la selección
nacional de Qatar están diciendo que
algunos no van a celebrar los goles
apoyando las protestas sociales vamos a
ver qué tan escandaloso podría hacer eso
pero lo cierto Es que Qatar está
haciendo lo suyo el mundial con más
inversión y está visibilizándose a nivel
mundial vamos a ver qué pasa seguro va a
haber mucha polémica y mucho escándalo
gran vitrina para acatar este mundial
pues ya veremos Cómo comienza esta Copa
del Mundo les agradezco muchísimo haber
estado con nosotros se nos fue el tiempo
volando como siempre aquí en una semana
en el mundo ustedes pueden seguir
dejando los comentarios a través de las
redes sociales y Pueden seguir en
sintonía de France 24 sigan con nosotros
[Música]